ALICIA WILLIAMS:
These days, it's
not enough for your
applications to be sometimes on.
They need a database that
maintains high availability
while handling increasing
and seasonal loads.
In today's episode of
Spanner Database Unlimited,
we'll show you under the hood
how Cloud Spanner provides
five nines.
That's 99.999% uptime for your
mission critical applications,
even at Google scale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Your customers
demand 24/7 access.
Every second your
data is unavailable,
you're losing money.
You're not able to process
orders, customers can't log in,
or perhaps your operations are
ground to a halt. Regulations,
such as ISO 27001
and HIPAA, require
availability guarantees.
For critical infrastructure
like health care
or financial
services, downtime can
have rippling effects into
the economy or public health.
So what are typical causes
of downtime for a database?
First, the
infrastructure can fail.
Disks die, routers melt
down, or memory is corrupted.
Spanner, like other
distributed systems,
handles these types of
failure by maintaining
separate copies of your data
across isolated infrastructure.
The more copies
and isolation, the
lower the probability
of a complete failure.
Let's dig into how
replication works in Spanner.
A regional instance
is composed of three
identical read-write replicas.
When you provision
one Spanner node,
you actually get
three units of storage
and compute that work together.
Each replica contains a
full copy of the database
and is hosted in a different
physical location or zone.
The zones are organized
to reduce the chances
that more than one will
fail at the same time,
for example, by having
independent power and cooling.
As data changes, Spanner
updates each of the replicas.
It uses the Paxos consensus
protocol and true time
to ensure these updates
are strongly consistent.
We'll dive into
Spanner's industry
leading consistency
guarantees in the next video.
If one zone becomes unavailable,
Spanner automatically
routes queries to
the other zones.
This all happens online, meaning
in-flight queries won't fail
and the database can continue
to handle queries and updates.
Once the zone comes
back up, it will
catch up from the other
replicas automatically
and resume handling
traffic once it's current.
No manual intervention is needed
and there's never any downtime.
Regional Spanner configuration
support up to four nines,
or 99.99% availability for
mission critical applications.
While very unlikely,
a region can
be a single point of
failure, for example,
in a natural disaster.
So Spanner also offers
multi-region configurations.
In this case, it
spreads data over
geographically dispersed
locations using
Google's dedicated network.
By spreading replicas over
multiple independent regions,
a multi-region
configuration can achieve up
to five nines of availability.
For the most demanding
uptime requirements,
such as in financial services,
online gaming and retail,
this is the level of
availability you need.
Spanner does a lot of
work behind the scenes
to ensure availability,
consistency, and performance
at scale.
Google's own applications
depend on it today.
However, to your developers,
it looks like a single scale
up database.
They don't have to worry
about brittle sharding,
eventual consistency,
or manual failover,
and can focus on innovation.
Another source of
potential downtime
is regular maintenance.
Software gets
updated, firmware is
patched, security policies are
revised, which in most cases
means bringing
down the database.
In a world of always-on access
and increasing interdependence
of business processes,
finding maintenance windows
across an application
set can be impossible.
With Spanner, though,
planned database maintenance
is a thing of the past.
Spanner is fully managed.
Google's best in class site
reliability engineering
ensures it's always up
to date, without having
to bring down the database.
A third source of
potential downtime
is changes in applications
that rely on the database.
If your application
requires a schema change,
like adding a new table
or changing a data type,
Spanner's unique
schema versioning
allows you to apply
changes to a live instance
without missing a beat.
Some schema updates are
applied immediately,
such as adding a
NOT NULL column.
Others require a validation
to avoid violating consistency
constraints or
require backfilling,
such as adding an index.
While this backfilling
happens automatically
in the background,
Spanner continues
to service queries against the
previous version of the schema.
Once the changes are completed,
it automatically switches over
to the new schema, providing
a 100% consistent view
of the data without
incurring any downtime.
Another application change
that can cause downtime, bugs--
for example, a delete that
leaves off aware condition
and deletes too much data,
or a calculation error that
corrupts data.
But Spanner provides
transactionally consistent
backups, allowing you to roll
back to a known good state.
This is possible because
every update in Spanner
happens at a time stamp.
Instead of changing
the data in place,
Spanner marks the
old data as expired
and new data is
available at this time.
Using this precise change
tracking, backups always
capture a consistent
snapshot of the data,
even as data is
updated during the time
it takes for the
backup to complete.
Restoring a consistent view
of the data from a backup
is simple and can be
online in minutes,
reducing the recovery time
objective during a disaster.
Today, we showed you how Spanner
provides availability at scale.
In the next episode,
we're diving
into Spanner's
consistency at scale.
If you thought you could
only have two of the three,
well, stay tuned for next
episode's conclusion.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for joining us today
on Spanner Database Unlimited.